you
welcome to part three of man media movie
month this week we're going to be
looking at Dan we have a problem the
script is well it's way too long I mean
I know we want dense but this is just
crazy
scanning through this you have notes on
objectification observers paradox
infinite regression active agents
passive agents fungibility vile ability
subjectivity instrumentality ownership
narrow definition of masculine and
fetishization we could spend the next
year working through these subjects and
still not be done yeah I know but all of
that stuff you also have two movies 300
and Fight Club as the centerpiece
callbacks to transformers and references
to Zardoz and you're trying to provide
context for all of them yeah here how
about I read you a choice quote and you
tell me how this sounds out loud in the
context of analyzing objectification the
observer's paradox takes on an
additional problematic dimension the
observer must try to observe
objectification using a brain that is
physically constructed to objectify
everything external to itself more than
just a paradox this is an infinite
regression because the solution to the
problem raises the same question that
was asked in the first place leaving us
with a paradox inside a paradox even
worse due to the fundamental nature of
the problem at hand the solution
requires an objective point of view that
would be so alien to the human point of
view that the answer would be
incomprehensible and thus useless
honestly you have to trim this it's it's
just too much for a 15-minute episode so
what do we cut first cut the Zardoz
reference in the callback to
Transformers I agree that it's
interesting to point out the michaela is
an active agent within the story yet is
treated by a prop by the camera but save
that for an episode on visual
characterization second tone down the
paradoxes next get down to the core what
is objectification how does it work and
where does it go wrong finally Fight
Club in 300 you have to pick one but you
have to pick man all right on one hand
my club has a lot of these questions
baked right into the movie men's
relationships with themselves in each
other their relation
women and their parents objectification
in media and its impact on individuals
in society and the movie sends mixed
messages by condemning the very things
that it's made out of effectively
demonstrating the paradoxical nature of
the problem yes on the other hand 300 is
so over the top of the Spanish ization
of the hyper masculine and the
progressive dimensional dehumanization
of the other that you can basically use
it as a scientific unit of my hmm what's
up
it's 117 minutes of sex violence and
one-liners the performances are sound
the characters are enjoyable the style
is interesting and the tone is
consistent as far as junk food
entertainment goes you can do a lot
worse and in a certain way I think it
even does exploitation and
objectification right or well as right
as you can do them so let's talk about
it
300 is a sticking point for me because I
know that on many levels it's in your
responsible film but I still love it but
I love its reckless disregard for
substance it's self-indulgent style and
its complete lack of self-awareness
every character is so thoroughly
stereotyped and exploited I'm amazed
no one twirls their moustache well my
monologuing about you like this guy not
man don't you just want a monologue and
twirl that sucker you're women
yeah that's right the story revolves
around half-naked white men murdering
foreigners and coded gays in a fantasy
version of the Battle of Thermopylae
King Leonidas leads the man out in the
battle well Queen Gorgo deals with the
political intrigue back home the 300
kill a bunch of soldiers horses ninjas
monsters grenadiers more monsters and
soldiers and then everyone dies many of
the complaints about the film stem from
how thin the characters are and Zack
Snyder's style over substance approach
to filmmaking and that's an absolutely
fair observation to make the characters
are paper-thin and generally disposable
not people just objects a real simple
way of illustrating this is by looking
at names how many characters from 300
can you remember by name Leonidas Xerxes
the feel tease maybe I know I'm not that
good with names to begin with but I've
seen the movie six or seven times now
and there's at least a dozen characters
whose names are only mentioned in
passing once maybe twice for the most
part the Spartan soldiers are referred
to as a collective horde simply being
called the 300 even individuals are
routinely referenced by their title or
role in the story The Hunchback the
traitor the Queen the son so why are
people not up in arms over this film's
objectification of men well it's
complicated
objectification is a challenging concept
to work with because it covers a very
wide range of behavior from vital to
survival on one end all the way to
morally decrepit on the other at the
most basic level objectification is the
mental process of turning abstract
concepts and stimulus into objects
if that sounds broad it's because it is
it's how your brain interprets the world
around you everything from the words I'm
saying to the chair you're sitting in to
the idea of love is translated from raw
stimulus into an object the brain then
takes these objects and files them away
in a complicated storage system that
relies heavily on patterns if this
sounds familiar it's because we kind of
already talked about this way back in
the first episode semiotics mimetics
language and the use of symbols all stem
from this process take those away and we
lose civilization and society heck in an
evolutionary sense this objectification
and pattern recognition system was vital
to our operation and survival because
without it the brain would need to spend
a ton of time and energy constantly
decoding the information coming in and
that time and energy is the difference
between living to have children and
ending up as wolf chow there's one more
important aspect of this that we need to
cover and that's the idea of scale or
dimension that's at work here
the further away you get from the
individual the less detailed the mental
object becomes a simple way of
explaining this is to think of a crowd
of people your brain doesn't see a
collection of individuals it just sees
well a crowd and treats them all like a
giant singular object it's like this
army here you don't think oh that's a
lot of individuals you think that's a
really big army so no matter what in
everyday life and a narrative some level
of objectification is inevitable you're
going to end up with disposable
interchangeable characters simply
because less important characters are
less important the further you get from
the main characters the more object like
the characters get that's just the
reality of it 300 provides perfect
examples of this to the point that you
can practically dry it out as a chart if
you place Leonidas at one end the
further away you get the less human the
characters become literally Leonidas
Xerxes the Queen the Greeks the
Hunchback the conscripts the Immortals
the monsters the animals
it's like sedimentary layers the
Immortals are the example I love the
most they're built up is this super
exotic fighting force they're identified
only as a collective group and they all
wear identical dehumanizing masks but
that's not all once the masks are off
their grotesque with inhuman eyes noses
and teeth the immortals are basically a
checklist of objectifying features
instrumentality they're a tool both for
the plot and for xerxes in the story
their only purpose is to demonstrate
that the 300 are mortal by killing a few
of them off agency they do what Xerxes
commands without question and act as a
swarm ownership there's Xerxes property
fungibility they're interchangeable lean
visually identical vile ability there is
no moral ambiguity in killing them
subjectivity their feelings motivations
and emotions are unimportant there you
go really you only need one of those for
a character to be considered an object
and these guys hit all six if we go
through the rest of the characters
almost all of them fall into one
category or another I'd probably say
that Leonidas Xerxes Queen Gorgo and a
feel tease escape that face but that's
still a bit hazy with the Queen and the
feel tease all right the film makes
objects of all its characters but to
what end
well fetishism and exploitation the core
values of the film are obvious which
violence is awesome manly men are
awesome girly men are evil pecs are
awesome violence is awesome sex is
awesome abs are awesome women are
awesome traitors suck and violence is
awesome that's mmm definitely not the
most wholesome message ever so why do I
like this movie first I would say its
fairness like crank - it treats everyone
with the same level of exploitation even
the enemies get to be awesome the
Immortals
awesome this executioner awesome the
Wizards awesome and let's look at the
Xerxes for a second he's coded queer
there's no question about that and he's
also foreign as the film's antagonist
he's the epitome of the other
exploitative very but you know what he's
still awesome yes he's the bad guy and
there's no question in the film's mind
that he should be treated as such
but he's in
awesome bad guy The Dude's ripped he's
like eight feet tall and that voice I
will erase even the memory of Sparta
from the histories every piece of great
parchment shall be burned every Greek
historian and every scribe shall have
their eyes put out and their tongues cut
for their mouths
why Murray the very name of Sparta or
Leonidas will be punishable by death the
world will never know you existed at all
so awesome he's the enemy but he's an
enemy you can get invested in like Darth
Vader he's intimidating powerful and
everything a good villain should be and
that brings us to the far end of the
spectrum where does objectification go
wrong the answer in my mind is volume
part of the reason I don't have a
problem with the overt objectification
of straight white men as violent maniacs
in 300 is because it's just one junk
food movie and I have hundreds of other
movies in my collection where straight
white men are complex active agents with
an historian not just plot objects other
groups within society while aren't that
lucky
when objectification or other mimetic
techniques are used repeatedly you get a
stereotype the noble leader the slimy
traitor the powerless good guy
the problem isn't stereotypes in and of
themselves it's when there's only
stereotypes and a lot of groups out
there really only get one or two
stereotyped roles to play over and over
and over again so I think the best
question 300 can make us ask is one of
empathy what if every movie was 300 no
kind of homely Tony Danza no mutant
Steve Buscemi no dull-eyed Shia LaBeouf
no pale scrawny Dan Olsen just sculpted
violence machines
so
yeah I'd probably stop going to the
movies too